mike fulton will be your pitcher for the
rangers tonight there's what he's done
in 23 starts this season and we
mentioned his recent success in the open
in the month of august his era is three
over 18 innings pitched on the 11 hits
given up three two pitch and that's way
in
in fact they're going to say that that
one
actually hit hannigan
really just been crushed by lefties as
he now faces kyle seeger
yahtzee out to right field another one
going deep for kyle seeger
number 27.
and kyle seeger just continues to
pulverize the texas rangers and the
mariners have a two nothing lead right
away
see the mayor score early veteran
left-hander marco gonzalez who's been on
a great roll last three starts one and
all with a 0.83 era
he hits his ball hard over third that's
a base hit and hernandez is on to start
the game
[Applause]
hot shot snared seeger toro at second
that's all they'll get more play fine
play by kyle on the backhanded side a
little bit of a bobble by toro
on the ground to seeger toro has it
second on to first base it is in time
for an inning ending double play
out walk to kellnig
raleigh swings and misses runner was
going to throw the second was high but
they
got him at second base
kinder philippa able to bring that one
down for a strike amount throw him out
double played in the inning
culverson good numbers in his career
against marco in strong numbers this
season against the mariners
off the plate and a soft fly ball to
kalnik
two out
curve chop back to marco softly he
handles it smooth as that as ever as
martin is retired
bouncer down to first base easy play for
culberson went away
[Applause]
there's a strike out of seeger
and a good bounce back third inning for
fulton
a one two three for him
[Applause]
this one lined into left field by
connor falefa
back-to-back two-out hits well he's got
a little something started now in this
third inning
swing and a miss top of the zone he gets
garcia
[Applause]
there's a ground ball shortstop
kind of on the run throws out france and
that's a first down of the inning
he likes to get after it his first
offering that one lined to the left side
of the infield and kenner falefa right
there to haul it in
how about a nine pitch inning
for mike
bottom of the fourth inning coming up
it's still two-nothing
the one-two
swing and a miss a funky looking swing
and a miss at that marco strikes out the
first man that he sees here in the
fourth
[Applause]
there's one lined up the middle that's a
base hit for culberson
and so he continues to dominate
left-handed pitching he has been
something else
martin's thinking bunt as the shift is
on there goes culberson and he's safe at
second base they're saying
jp missed the tag
that was a delayed steal
here we go
he's out
out number three culberson cut down at
second base
2-2
and there's the swing of the mist
horrends strikes out that's the third
strike out of the night
for fulton
he strikes out again
in fact faulty gets a couple of punch
outs in the fifth
want some paint on the outside corner
there is out number one
[Applause]
this ball smashed deep out to center
that could be trouble off the top of the
fence
trevino to second it'll pull up there
with a two-out double he missed a home
run
by maybe two three inches we're
literally talking inches maybe two
two inches more
and that thing bounces off the top of
the fence
and goes over that is as close as you
can come
right to jp crawford he's able to keep
his glove on his hand that was smoked
right at him
and it ends the rangers fit
[Applause]
hits his ball hard out to right field
that'll be extra bases
hanegar got a good start he's to third
base they'll wave him toward the plate
here comes the throw the tag and they
got him
yet another outfield assist
from el bombie that 11 this year yes it
is
you see the footwork and he goes after
it hard but he collects himself knowing
that he's gonna need a quick release
scoops it up quickly gets it in
and wow fernandez makes a good strong
throw but he's got good enough arm
strength to get it all the way there
that gives trevino a little extra time
where this play at the plate wasn't even
close
this one off the handle toward first
base
and culverson feeding fulton emmits not
really necessary but that's okay good
job on faulty's part to stick with it
the inning is done some good defense by
the rangers again a call for the offense
offense kind of full up it
counter falefa hits this ball hard out
to left field fraley had a bad read on
it and almost plugged right at the base
of the fence
connor falefa with a double to start the
sixth inning here is casey sadler in the
sixth inning scott service looking for
him to get through this sixth inning
they appeal
there's a water balloon thrown down to
first base
to complete it sadler retires peters and
pozo
and there's another one and it's pretty
well struck deep out to center calmness
can't get to it and it bounces up into
the rangers bullpen for the automatic
double all right the guy who really
drove the ball his last time up to
trevino
that ball hit hard down the right field
line that'll be extra bases here comes
the bagnes he scores trevino to second
base it's a one-run game in the seventh
inning
jose trevino
represents the tying run out there in
scoring position
[Applause]
strike three called top shelf strike
and it ends the seventh
raleigh stings this out to right field
and it's over the leap of garcia
kelnick is past second he pedals into
third raleigh is safe at second base and
the mariners have runners on the corners
out to right field
garcia makes the catch plenty deep
counter comes home and scores for some
insurance meanwhile raleigh takes third
on a sac fly off the bat at jp crawford
and the mariners extend the lead three
to one
skied
to jp crawford
underneath it seawall retires the side
in order second riders o2
ground ball
into the shift
crawford easy play stacking rider
retires this side in order the mariners
win it 3-1 they win their third straight
series